hey everyone and welcome to another hd
tutorial this one is actually a request
video and you can see by the title i'm
going to be showing you guys how to
erase and basically get rid of that
annoying green
zoom square uh whenever you're editing a
video in camtasia studio 6. so i'm
actually just going to open up camtasia
studio 6 here and we can tell now that
it's open and this is actually a very
simple process so it's a short tutorial
just go to the tools button
and you can see as i zoom into the tools
button or zoom out of it here there was
no green hint uh square so again go to
tools go to options and this options
window will come up and we're going to
go actually to the zoom tab
and we're going to change uh at on
normally the apply zoom and pan hints
button will be checked if you uncheck
that you will no longer have that little
green
square whenever you zoom in and out of
your films just hit ok
and that change will be applied so
whenever you zoom in and out of
something in camtasia studio 6 now that
green button will not be there in the
preview and that's basically it so i
hope this tutorial was helpful and thank
you for requesting the video your link
is in the description and have a nice
afternoon peace